[Musique]
la à grandir en tant que barbare très
bizarre à dire et je pense que les gens
ont vu aussi j'étais beaucoup plus
affirmée beaucoup plus épanouie je pense
que la barbara de 15 ans serait ou là
qui tu sais moi ça vraiment
[Musique]
oui
mes parents ont font des gros joueurs de
jeux vidéo et donc ça a toujours quelque
chose qui a été dans ma vie et qui était
logique c'est moi j'ai jamais eu le 30
minutes d'internet et puis maintenant on
s'en va dans mon père me faisait jouer
avec lui sur des mmorpg il faisait fermé
à sa place ma mère me faisait des nuits
blanches pour qu'on joue à des jeux
d'horreur [ __ ] j'ai été pas forcément
très sociable et j'avais beaucoup de
soucis au collège et au lycée
je n'avais pas énormément d'amis et
j'étais très solitaire et le fait
d'avoir le jeu ça m'a permis on va dire
de me faire une bulle
surtout que je faisais du mmorpg donc
c'est du jeu en ligne et on discute avec
beaucoup de gens et moi j'avais des amis
sur internet et beaucoup moins dans la
braise un peu comme aujourd'hui
quand mes parents ont divorcé g on va
dire que j'ai arrêté le lycée parce que
si je n'étais pas bien du tout dedans et
donc j'ai passé un bac en candidat libre
alors que j'étais en scientifique j'ai
passé un bac littéraire va chercher la
logique
[Musique]
le divorce de mes parents en fait m'a
permis de on va dire si on charge est
positif
ça m'a permis de me débrouiller tout
seul très très vite d'être très
indépendante et dès là je savais que je
voulais un travail qui n'avaient pas
forcément de cadres 8h 18h
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais qu'est ce qu'ils
vont penser de moi est ce qu'est ce
qu'ils vont dire de moi ça se trouve on
est gentil sur le chat mais derrière je
vais avoir des tweets sur moi ça va être
difficile à gérer
ça va peut-être être la pire idée de ma
vie et au final
pendant la première heure c'était très
difficile parce que j'étais gêné et josé
pas trop rigoler j'avais des petits
regards qui partait partout je regardais
pas ma caméra et au bout d'une heure je
me suis un peu déliées
je me suis en fait c'est génial les gens
sont gentils ils viennent pas pour être
méchant avec moi s'ils viennent c'est
parce qu'ils ont choisi de venir
et regardez de parler avec moi
[Musique]
du coup je me suis lancée sur twitter où
j'ai je me suis dit on va s'amuser on va
jouer aux jeux vidéo et puis on va faire
ce que je voulais faire quand j'étais
ado partager ma passion
les jeux vidéo les mangas parler des
films à prendre étudier faire plein de
choses avec d'autres gens je me faisais
sur twitch c'est la meilleure façon de
le faire et du coup je me suis dit aussi
moi je veux créer une ses flèches je
veux un endroit où personne ne
discrimine personne parce que ça sera ma
maison pour moi mon stream c'est ma
maison en fait et je vais en droit qui
positif ils sont massés fly100 fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
stream et plus de deux heures devant des
gens animés avoir un minimum de skill
sur le jeu lire un chat faire attention
à la caméra donc tu peux pas mettre ton
doigt dans le nez tu peux tu dois être
droit tu monte naturelle mais jouer
devant une caméra
c'est complètement différent que de
jouer sans caméra et d'être tranquille
deux ans dans son petit canapé déjà rien
que ça ça t'épuises moi je sais que
quand je fais mes 4 5 heures voire plus
de live à la fin je suis épuisé je ne
peux pas je ne parle plus pendant une
heure je suis un peu en silence monacal
je ne parle plus j'ai besoin de me
ressourcer
il ya une époque où je live et entre 8
et 10 heures par jour et je prenais même
un jour voir pas jour de repos par
semaine donc 10 heures de live de trois
heures d'administratifs d'appel de
tournage etc et donc je me stopper
jamais et en plus de ça je prenais
quelques vagues de harcèlement par sur
twitter par mail etc
et en fait je m'en suis pas rendu compte
mais j'ai mon cerveau a fait en fait un
trop plein
[Musique]
un peu l'ombre de moi-même où je prenais
plus en moi je sortais plus je faisais
plus de sport je faisais que du stream
du string du stream et ça m'arrivait
aussi de pleurer d'être mal et de me
dire mais les gens ne m'aiment pas je
prenais que les avis et en fait c'est à
partir de cette période que je me suis
dit mais il faut que tu te relèves
barbara et là c'était pas mal là c'était
à barbara de se relever parce que ça en
fait c'est attaquer magra mais ça
touchait barbara est en fait c'est à
partir de ça je me suis dit ça n'a pas
dans un bon sens c'est mauvais et j'ai
tout repris j'ai pris du temps pour moi
j'ai repris le sport et je pense que je
vais aussi un déclic qui fait que depuis
ce moment là les avis négatifs mukul
dessus je pense qu'il sait facile de
perdre le train de perdre pied dans ce
milieu et c'est quelque chose que je
veux je veux toujours me rappeler d'où
je viens toujours me rappeler pourquoi
je fais ça me dire que ben ouais j'ai la
chance en fait et ça c'est quelque chose
que je me rappelle tous les jours c'est
important je pense qu'on ya beaucoup de
gens qui rêveraient d'être streamer et
qui l'ont pas forcément ou qui sont en
train de travailler comme comme des fous
pour alors tous les jours je remercie ça
il ya vraiment vraiment utile mais je
trouvais sur le mec qui bosse but
ben voilà c'est ma vie en fait